i want to talk about the tbs tournament
of laughs because we are no longer on
the show
and we were robbed and i love jim norton
and i
i respect him and i hope he wins he's
going up against piff the magic dragon
what an honor and
here's a reality we got to the final
four and we were let go
it's it hurts me what's your dream out
there do you have one
because my dream was to win the
tournament of laughs
on tbs when i got into comedy when i
first started doing it in a coffee house
there was also a tattoo parlor in long
island new york
okay where people would go in with like
tattoos of [ __ ]
some ex-girlfriend and they had to get
them made into something patriotic
you know can you yeah her name's kerry
can you cover that up and put blue lives
matter
please and i started there and when i
started there i dreamed that one day
there'd be a pandemic i prayed i said
hopefully
a decade in a comedy right as i'm
starting to sell tickets
there'll be a pandemic it'll shut down
the whole operation none of us will be
able to leave our homes
we'll only be able to upgrade lo-fi
sketches and we'll have to come and not
just to enjoy them to compete with each
other
that's what matters comics competing
with each other
during a pandemic not to raise money for
anything just to
do it so i dreamed of this and it was my
life's work i fought and i worked and i
and i said to myself
if we do the right things and if china
leaks a bio weapon that the us and china
probably invented together
the only time they're gonna how great is
it gonna be when we find out the only
time
that we ever got along with china is
when we created coronavirus
because that book's coming out in five
years coronavirus was created it like
some like
u.s joint china thing i guarantee you
we're involved with china and we all
there's there's
definitely a photo of [ __ ]
us and china eating ramen and with a bat
and we said look at this [ __ ]
we're just having fun
it was some like weird convention for
[ __ ]
you know bio research darpa [ __ ] and
they created and cooked up this thing i
guarantee it
it's coming out in a few years that book
by the way
and i said i said hopefully that happens
because i want to be in a position where
i can compete
tournament laughs so we made it to the
finals
we didn't think we were gonna make it
there the competition was fierce
i mean fierce these other comics were
you know on drugs in homeless shelters
uploading
videos on their iphones we didn't think
we could beat them
how could we know that we were going to
to be able to beat them you know
i i don't know what did we went up
against fortune themes to one
i don't know what happened i don't know
what her video was she was stuck in a
revolving door
i don't know it's not my fault it's not
my problem i respect her
the point is this we won we persevered
okay
and then we got to the finals to do
battle with norton
and whatever the magic dragon is and
he's one america's got talent or
something i don't know
good for him i should dress up like a
magic dragon
now you know what i was thinking by the
way the other you know david dobrik
goes around and gives people and the
face uh clan and face rug whoever these
people are
uh face covet whoever they are they give
people the lamborghinis
i said to myself what if i went around
and instead of give it giving
people a lamborghini i'd give them like
a a a stern talking to
like instead of when somebody's working
at starbucks instead of showing up with
a lamborghini
i show up i drag them outside and they
they're getting really excited like what
am i gonna get and i go what are you
doing
what are you doing with your life let's
talk
why do they cry when they get the car by
the way i know i've brought this up why
do you cry
now you got to go to lamp you got a
starbucks with a lamborghini now
everybody hates you
your life is still shitty you can just
get to the horrible job
faster thank you for getting me this car
that's going to get
stolen and smashed and so i can
race to my job that i hate faster
thank you so much i'm crying thank you
for this
lamborghini that a company gave you to
give me
thank you tim dillon doesn't do that i
show up with a chris hedges book
america the farewell tour and i say
there you go
no price on knowledge how about that
i think that's a good show what if i
follow david dobrik around and i give
him beaters
like old cars that people have died in
with his like blood and
guts what if i give david dobrik cars
police cars that were burned in the
riots
just to
he looks like a chipmunk you want to eat
his face
that's why so goddamn successful
everyone i insult on the show i want to
be by the way ellen david dobrik the
mossad
so we get
we get to the finals of tournament laps
which is literally the only thing we've
we've ever really tried for i mean
hard hard we tried yeah we made it past
levels and layers and yes you're telling
me tim you never told anyone to vote you
barely posted a link
you didn't know when the show was on the
website kept crashing
uh you know your aunt who supports
everything you do referred to the show
as a total embarrassment
um it was my aunt said it was so bad it
was literally confusing
um she didn't know it was your show you
know
that's good but i i
loved it i love being a part of it i
love having the honor
of being because i've loved tbs get up
the shows tbs is done
get get up what tbs has done now
you're lucky your ass got edited on that
channel
get up with tbs. the samantha b show
thank you very much the best political
satire that's ever been made
why cause she's yelling and it's about
trump
that's what she does it's trump
uh yeah yes i was happy
to be on a network that had angie
tribeca
yes pull up angie try becca please
it's an american comedy television
series
tribeca is a squad of lapd detectives
who investigate
the most serious cases from the murder
of a ventriloquist
to the rash of baker suicides angie
works best alone
the only problem she has a new partner
jay the squad also includes
a pop apoplectic captain chet
atkins quirky bespeckled medical
examiner dr monica scholes
and detective dj tanner this was my
favorite show
[Music]
okay else have they done up there
they just buy shows from other places
what about miracle workers
[ __ ] yeah bring up miracle workers on
tbs
this is what daniel radcliffe was in
miracle workers on tbs
man frustrated with the current state of
earth
god has pretty much given up to focus on
petty hobbies
thinking the end might be near two
determined angels try to change his mind
craig and eliza low-level angels
responsible for handing
handling all of humanity's prayers must
convince their boss
to save humanity and answer their most
impossible prayer yet
help two humans laura and sam fall in
love
the seven episode limited series based
on simon rich's book
turns the perception of heaven upside
down
do you people understand what an honor
it was
to be on this network that had shows
like
samantha b yells about trump angie
tribeca and whatever the hell this was
with daniel radcliffe and steve buscemi
were on it
and lauren michaels produced it well boo
boo hoo good
it's great anyway
i have no beef with laura michaels by
the way i'm available email me
i'll delete this whole show i'll delete
i will delete this whole show sir if you
get behind my career i'll act like it
never happened
i'll act like it never happened i'll
walk into the green room of ellen and
just throw hot acid in those [ __ ]
[ __ ] faces
i will if ellen comes back i will be the
person who sprays mace
at the c segment producers if they get
mouthy
so we've already established tbs as a
phenomenal channel
we were lucky to be on it okay
lucky and we got to the finals and then
we said let's
let's kick it up let's kick it up a
little bit
let's not do the normal what we're doing
you know how we usually work together
and just it's me and him
we hired a crew we hired lights we had
producers we had we had about a crew of
eight people
to do these sketches literally that i
spent i spent 30
000 dollars producing each one of these
sketches which i will show for you right
now
they're they're good not yet not yet i
don't mean right now i mean broadcast
right now
in 38 minutes i'm kidding it's coming
soon
but i want to set the stage i spent 30
000
of whitney cummings money
[Laughter]
buying producers editors writers we had
the best team i mean these people
they had been behind the best shows
angie tribeca
the the big guys samantha bee yells
about trump
all the good shows we hired the best
people
okay dps and line producers you people
don't know you're not in the biz
but we got everybody we got everybody we
got the guys who made the videos of abu
grape
of them raping people which seymour
hirsch said they have
and then the cia destroyed we got those
guys to do the videography
they were the same people on epstein's
island we got those people the people
that installed the blackmail equipment
and little st james came and they helped
us make these videos because they
understand
how to when something is high stakes
they get it
they get it so that's what we got we
spent a lot of money yes was it morally
questionable sure
but we wanted to win because this was my
dream
we poured our heart and soul into it we
took a week to write
a week ben came over we stayed
one week we didn't sleep we used drugs
adderall cocaine whatever
we were huffing household cleaner
anything to write these sketches we were
tripping mushrooms lsd
ayahuasca we were wandering around the
desert our third eye was
open we were talking to god and the
aliens
everything that we could do to enrich
ourselves so that the that our bodies
and minds would be used as
vessels and that those vessels
would be able to deliver a message from
another world
maybe to the people of earth that the
highest level of art
art in the sense of the priest and the
shaman
that's what we were doing we wanted to
have a religious
experience these sketches we put more
work into these sketches
than anything and they refused to
air them on television
they refused to air them on
television and i literally do not
understand why these are the most
intelligent sketches they are
smart they are sharp and they show that
we not only took this show
seriously but we have respect for the
craft of comedy
and for the great network of tbs who
brought you
great shows like samantha bee yells
about the president of the united states
for 28 minutes
and then angie tribeca
which i've never seen don't don't start
messaging me audrey hey just rebecca's
not even that bad
there's somebody out there right now is
like oh you're sitting on here
you better understand and you try becca
was coming i've never
watched it we're gonna play the first
sketch now
this sketch um
took four days to shoot
how many to edit three three or four
yeah
in an editing room you had three editors
working with you mm-hmm day and night
day and night and they refused
to put this on television on the tbs
network
so now we're going to show you this
sketch which literally i've never worked
harder at anything
than i have doing this and i submitted
it to the tbs network
and they did not air it on television
and i want to know why
and i i and and maybe some of you could
let me know because when you see this
you're going to see how hard we [ __ ]
worked
hey look at this guy over here yeah
my name is frank fauci i'm tony pouchy's
son
in italy what we do is we go right in
the bath like this
we're going to bath in italy everyone
italy
you got to go to italy
[Music]
and it'll even go right to the map
forget about it somebody's scooping
so forget about it oh yeah
forget about it hey my father gonna
figure it out
my name is frank fauci the fauci
family name i have a lot of pride in
that
don't be stupid forget about it this
coronavirus
hey look at this guy over here yeah
my name is frank fauci i'm tony pouchy's
son
he's the [ __ ] doctor tony thought
she's the doctor forget about
hey hey coronavirus say forget about it
right what are you doing
what are you gonna do my father tony
thought she the country's in good hands
daddy gonna handle it come on down daddy
gonna handle it
he gonna get everybody vaccinated come
on don't worry about nothing forget
about it eh
hey come on donny falchi
when i was growing up my father used to
say to me is to say hey little frankie
you better be uh you better get your
vaccine
i'm making my favorite drink like this
i can put the water from the sinker like
that
like that okay and then i put it in here
like it is forget about it
i take it through the brush i stir it
like that
forgot about it honey foundation son
frank fashion
yeah look at this guy here no coveriana
look at this guy yeah he likes it
forget about it look at him
it is an insult to me and to you and to
the time we spent on that that that was
not aired on television
truly and if the the ceo of that company
uh and the producers of that show do not
recognize that
for what it is and i don't wanna i don't
wanna be a part of it if you do not
recognize that sketch
and if you don't see the hours that we
put into that if you can't tell the
manpower
if you don't understand the team of
people that we assembled
to put something like that together
because we respect this show
and the network if you don't get it
i i am i wrong here
when i say that when you watch that
sketch
you think to yourself how in god's name
did they do it with only 30 grand how
did they
come up with this we're doing game of
thrones level
[ __ ] here on on you know champagne
taste on a beer budget i mean
now that sketch i was frank uh dr
fauci's son frank fauci
and that was written and rewritten and
we had a team of writers kind of coming
up with those lines
and yes there was a lot of repetition of
the
yes yes there was but it was driving a
point home
okay about the natural state of chaos it
is the world
and that you have to quite literally
forget about it
which i thought was a pretty good
message to deliver to tbs
the cowards the cowards at tbs
did not want to put that on the air and
to me
a little upset a little upset at the
producer that we worked with who lived
uh in a small shanty by the 405 who we
used to facetime with
uh she lived literally her balcony was
in lane
two of the 405 and i every time i had to
face them with her i'd go are you okay
um
i'm a little upset that she didn't fight
harder to get that on the air
i'm a little upset at my friend maureen
who decided to uh
to green light the show and then move to
canada go move to an igloo for
seven months and uh abandon us all
abandon the artists
what about the artists
okay we don't deserve this the people
working on ellen
yes they deserve what they got that's
different
we're going to show the second sketch
now the second sketch was
even harder
the degree of difficulty have you ever
watched the olympics
you ever watched the summer olympics me
and my father used to like the winter
olympics because the speed skaters had
fun names like hey chavo
now and it wasn't racist we like to say
them hey chavo and we'd eat
ice cream pints of haagen-dazs and watch
the winter olympics and then it was here
people would fall and whatever and
you know then the skier had a fun name
peek-a-boo street she was a white chick
um and then there were other good names
too i forget
um we always liked watching the russian
gymnasts because you know we knew
that there were stakes and when they
you know when they when they didn't
stick that landing in gymnastics they
went back
to russia and they were literally the
shame of the nation you know and then
their their families would be
assassinated
and we felt like that we liked that
you know and when i would watch the
olympics
you would you would you would see those
gymnasts and they'd have to stick the
land and you'd have to stick it you
couldn't step back you could
have to stick that landing you couldn't
stumble and fall and i feel like with
this next sketch
we stuck the [ __ ] landing
we did a brilliant sketch that was
complex that was layered
had multiple meanings we had a lot going
on in the sketch
and if you know us that's not what we
usually do we usually do like a minute
or two fun topical thing
this was a real narrative
piece that we put together that the
cowards
at tbs refused to air thereby robbing us
of our rightful victory and our place in
the uh
i imagine the television hall of fame
i don't know but i'm just guessing that
that's where we would have ended up
so without further ado i'm going to play
you maybe the greatest piece of art that
me or benjamin will ever produce in our
lives
and again the cowards at tbs would not
let you see this but we will
right here on the tim dillon show
i just came home right and look here
this lady's going through my mail who
are you i'm the owner of this house so
what i'm a neighbor in the community
and i go around and i read people's mail
to help them
who do you think you are what are you
crazy
you go back to your own country you
british bastard
you goddamn limey brit you go back to
your own country
you've gone full mental i'm not mitchell
your mitchell
we beat you in the civil war we'd be
britain in the civil war
is that your dog yeah i'm gonna kill
your dog
oh my god i'm gonna kill your dog your
stupid [ __ ]
oh christ oh now you sound australian
are you stupid what's going on
i'm i'm a white woman
i'm a white woman and i'm
the i'm in charge of the country i'm
president of my own [ __ ]
i'm president of my own [ __ ]
i'm going to party in your house i'm
happy
i'll kill you get out of here you want
to have sex with me
no i'll have sex with you
i'm having a party
[Music]
all right get out of here no you're not
you want my tent
i'm having a body
having a poor tournament kiss my ass
turn him into laughs kiss my ass
turn him into laughs kiss my ass
get it
attack
yeah chicken yeah
you
[Music]
[Laughter]
i mean the proof is in the pudding the
proof is in the pudding to not put that
on
on the air to deny the effort
that went into that to me is criminal
completely criminal and i am
a little disappointed